[Music]
patrick is with us in fort myers florida
hi patrick welcome to the ramsey show
hi how you doing better than i deserve
what's up in your world
basically i'm trying to see if i can
justify myself a new crook
okay
my wife and i basically we live in our
paychecks not counting our investments
73 000 a year on the take-home pay
and i'm looking at a forty five thousand
dollar truck
why apparently we have
currently we have
is really good except for the mortgage
on my home
[Music]
and a two-year fully funded emergency
fund
okay
along with that i've been doing extra
payments on my current truck which i
bought in 2006.
i fully paid that off and i continued
making payments and have a
savings account of approximately eighty
two thousand dollars well that's good
well number one rule is number one rule
when you're getting ready to buy cars
can you pay cash for it and the answer
is obviously you can pay cash for it is
this a new truck
no it's actually about 2007
okay
all right
um
and the other the other thing we tried
the other rule of thumb we use patrick
is that the thing the largest thing we
all buy that goes down in value
is a car
and things that go down in value defeat
our wealth building plan they work
against us to build wealth obviously if
they're going down in value and so we
try to not to put too much into things
that are going down in value because the
goal here is to build wealth so that you
can drive anything you want to drive and
not have to worry about it and so the
rule we've used for years is don't buy
things with motors and engines all added
together that's more than half your
annual income and this is
well actually when i say that's my
annual income that's just what we live
on it's not counting all the revenue we
get from the business that we own as
well of our original income well then
that's not your income
what is your annual income
my annual income is 382 000.
okay well then you can afford a 45 000
truck if you pay cash for it as long as
the other car is not a hundred and fifty
thousand dollar vehicle
the other car is already paid off anyway
it doesn't matter if it's paid off
if it's a lamborghini you can't have the
truck but otherwise you can get the
truck yeah i mean here because you know
you got plenty of money it's not it's
not your salaried income it's the income
the point is
we're trying to measure and say is this
are you putting too much of your life in
things that are going down in value when
you have a 300 000 income and 80 000 in
the bank to buy the thing with
45 000 is not too much of your life yeah
absolutely i mean that those numbers
change everything when i thought you
were making 73 and you want to buy a 46
000 truck i mean that's that's insane
but based on the numbers you just shared
with us this is a fine move i would
question you know are you is this just a
fun toy i mean you guys have worked
really hard you said you had a two-year
emergency fund yeah it's a little steep
you guys go all in on whatever it is so
it sounds like he's going all in on this
truck and you have the money for it i
don't see a problem with that
yeah and i would adjust your emergency
fund to six months and invest the
difference or put it onto your mortgage
if you got a mortgage still so
those are the kinds of things but if you
make 300 000 a year and you have the
money to pay cash for a 45 000 truck and
it's not brand new
no problem if it is brand new and your
net worth is over a million no problem
do it you know that's still just fine